I think we have someone joining us hello
right now are you let's see I didn't get
anything like hello hi are you driving
are you in the back you got the memo
read well I look so well so I'm in yours
wait a minute did they give you that
shirt to wear for this interview no I
just happened to have it having the
warning so dude so I just went on
Chelsea I accidentally said that on air
that you were gonna come next time and
not bring your wife but I immediately
regretted it cuz I love your wife and I
was like don't sit don't worry
about EVO Beale case you got embarrass
you'll be embarrassed again so is there
anything about you know what surprised
you watching it that you didn't expect
based on what happened with you guys
in chess cajones well I didn't realize
that he was quite as I guess you
cut me deep don't worry it'll come back
around but I have to add to heal
completely
yeah a lot of coffee I think we're on
lockdown
yeah I just did an interview I'm talking
about I miss old I want to tell them
everything I know which is absolutely
nothing yes exactly we actually do know
nothing but I'm I can say I'm very much
looking forward to working with Mike and
everybody you know involved I think the
team up will be really fun you know they
keep hitting him out of the park so it's
like it's exciting world to be a part of
what for you is the most surprising
response to Jessica Jones
I mean the script is so so strong I knew
you had a really strong reaction when
you read it but what surprised you most
about the public reaction to it well I
definitely you know the life after the
show it's that it's beyond what we could
have ever imagined
you know it's Netflix dreams in a lot of
countries so it's it's a huge amount of
exposure and you know you want your work
to be seen as long as it's good so this
has been a really just a really cool
experience to do something that we're
all so proud of and the work is cool and
the characters are cool and it's also
reaching like a giant audience but it's
definitely it definitely changes you
know changes things a little bit with
something that's not Netflix you know
obviously you're not dealing with
commercials and actrix and things like
that does it change the way that the
flow of the scripts and the rhythm for
you pass it off I think you know there's
a lot of time back right so that's like
oh it's like 10 minutes 12 minutes that
you get back and I think they spend a
lot of the time with the character is
the quiet moment so my favorite moments
in Jessica Jones and Luke Cage or when
you have like just nothing's going on or
just staying on somebody's face for a
long time and because of that you get
this like intimacy with your characters
that doesn't doesn't come around all the
time I think that's one of the great
benefits just getting that extra time
don't worry you're gonna have a
revolving door of women coming in I mean
cast members I mean you guys met in you
guys met you did chemistry reads
together you can get through this
together from the very beginning of the
audition process right yeah we we kind
of you know kind of you know just met
like I remember it was actually not too
long ago I was just over than the area
just now you know with ABC studios and
over on the Disney lot that's what we
have to be we did the auditions in the
chemistry reads and you know first time
I met Kristen I walk into rooms her and
several other women and and you know I
approach everything he's ideally in my
head I think about I am on I'm in New
York at the moment we're just filming
with we're shooting with shooting the
finale at the moment sorry
yeah let's see it's uh 638 hop six yeah
you're done done for the day
no no we're just starting which is six
pm finishing at 6:00 a.m. yeah it's
gonna be a long long night see people
don't get that they don't know how hard
you work this is a chance for people out
there live to know exactly what we're
going through in your lives
people are unwinding you're just
starting your day you're gonna work all
throughout the night whether it's
sleeping having together going to happy
hour it's gonna be good
are you doing anyway nice nice to
finally meet you this is the first time
that me and Mike are actually probably
meeting for the first time kind of super
amazing super weird I tried to catch you
guys at Gramercy Park but you guys
started too late again I couldn't wait
oh sorry okay nice
which one the defenders well he's Doug
he's almost done at this so he's I feel
bad for him because I kind of would do
similar things when I you're not gonna
get any break I mean you're pretty much
gone right into defenders but luckily
you're half my age so you can take it I
mean you're young man you could do this
I don't I would I don't know what I
could do yeah I think I've got like a
three week break until we start
defenders so it's nice I'm just gonna go
shoot off up into the Upstate somewhere
just kind of like get the hell out of
New York for a little bit you know UK
now heading back to the UK to visit no
no I'm okay for Christmas see my father
and I just figured like if I'm just been
doing this for like so long I just want
I'm gonna go away be around no one for
like two weeks and just honey don't be
in the wilderness you know it'd be nice
anyway I just went to say hello
congratulations on the show I'm on my
three at the moment it's really great
I'm looking forward to working back
thanks man yeah face to face or via via
the internet yeah yeah pretty much
yes that was it so you're having a good
time I saw I saw Christian and then I
saw fin yeah just I just a hell of a fin
for the first time ever
let's head that was history was just
made yep
no I'm actually I'm in New York
of all places I'm on the Punisher set
and then I leave that set to go join
Finn and I'll be with him all night yeah
I know anything talk about the long
nights that you have but you know we
we're on we're on both shows so I know I
know you get no rest that's why there
are two of you but true story and Mike
knows the story uh
when he came in for his first audition
he and I came up on the elevator
together and we were the only two on the
elevator and he got off on the third
floor and I went to the fifth floor and
came in and I said I just came up on the
elevator with you came up with a guy who
looks like no I came up with we got here
look at the distance looks good in it he
was in a coffin I was like this oh do
you think actors do anything but free
come on guys I wanted to say that you
know as I said I've only just started
watching it but um the I love the show
man a special shout-out to um to the
costume department and Stephanie for
that hoodie man with the yellow lining
oh this is poor details
cool that's a that's like one of the
greatest Easter eggs I have one of those
actually I should wear that right now I
have the exact lady right now I decided
to wear this at all so don't give me
this did you get the memo
Netflix read its did you get the memo
daredevil read daredevil read it's the
same thing it's the same thing yeah I've
got a question did actually pertains to
you that a fan sent in so Eric C asks if
Luke found out that the Punisher was in
Harlem going after various criminal
elements would he stop him or let him be
no I'm not gonna stop him you know I
don't I don't get blood on my hands but
I got stop him from taking out some dirt
bags firearms in the first episode of
your show I bring him up
you grab the gun right and it goes off
in your hand yeah how did you decide
like how would it how did you decide
what level of pain that is like what did
you come up with that like how much does
that mean for me I thought of it be more
of cuz I don't think it's ever happened
before for Kiki Luke did that I don't
think I don't think he's ever put a
pistol in his head and have to go up in
his palm so I think it was more like
it's almost like a firecracker or a
small flag right that's cool man I love
it well listen I'm absolutely loving it
I'm so thrilled I can't wait I can't
wait till you get here and we can start
we can start defending it I know the
friend arena together and for long very
long long nights
oh he's you know he's just a big he's a
big kid I mean jail is like Peter he is
he's like I don't know he's the
incarnation of joy there if you kind of
like I mean he's just always in a good
mood and always happy and I don't know
what I'm like I think I saw him like
like sit a little bit once it's so hard
to get him going but he takes everything
in stride Mike thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to the fans
Marvel fans thank you guys so much for
tuning in talking with all of our
Netflix shows keep the questions coming
thank you guys
much and we will see you next time thank
you